you do talk a lot about conspiracy
theories and I've seen you talk about
you know aliens and JFK assassination
and all this stuff it's fun to debunk
this stuff right it's sort of fun to to
think about them you know whether even
even 9/11 thinking you know at least
entertaining the ideas whatever they may
be that our government did it or this or
that whatever it is it's sort of fun to
always entertain those ideas but
basically you come down on all this
stuff that I think what Carl Sagan would
say that extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence is that did I sum
up your yes it's you on how to deal with
this stuff yes absolutely the thing with
conspiracy theories that are different
than other claims that we deal with it
skeptic is they do happen there are
conspiracies Watergate was a conspiracy
the assassination of Lincoln was a
conspiracy you know and you know there's
all those stories about the stuff that
Kissinger was orchestrating and you know
South American dictatorships we like
this dictator versus deictic we're
pulling the strings we're sending money
arms for hostage was going on those are
conspiracies right definition and so we
have to acknowledge that that does
happen but of course the conspiracy
theory is the fact that that happened
over there means that my pet theory must
be right not necessarily not all
conspiracies so how do we tell the
difference what's the criteria well the
sort of conspiracy detection kit like
the baloney detection kit where you know
the more people that have to be involved
the less likely the theory isn't gonna
be true because people are incompetent
they can't keep their mouth shut we find
out about it I remember I was on G
Gordon Liddy's radio show back in the
90s and he asked me about conspiracies I
was like well you know I didn't want to
say this but you couldn't even break
into a hotel room I mean you know people
have this vision of you know governments
as these super powerful agents that can
do anything
mostly they're just like bureaucrats at
the DMV right that's what you're dealing
with right so in a way it's the same
thing as religion the people that are
going down the conspiracy paths they
want some easy answer yeah or an
extremely complex issue that we really
often have no answer for economy is not
this complex system that no one can
really understand or predict it's it's
of guys living in London calling the
shots the Illuminati and yeah they're
pulling the strings and making this
happen and so it is the same thing as
religion because that feels nice if you
if you could sort of wrap yourself
around that but that's how the world
actually operates we'd sort of the same
thing is you know well there's a god and
I'm gonna believe that because it is
like a god or Committee of gods or
something that's yeah pulling the
strings and it grants way more power
than they than anybody actually has
which is what we grant to gods that they
have more power than we have otherwise
they wouldn't be gods right you know so
what's the point of that and so yeah we
work through those and now politically
since we've talked about left and right
that 9/11 is an interesting take because
that seems to be more on the left and
left and right both have their own
hand-picked conspiracies that they
prefer like like but the anti-vaxxers
tend to be a little bit of both you get
anti-government right and then think the
government is in cahoots with Big Pharma
and then the left well Big Pharma is
making money off a vaccine so you get a
little bit of both right that's
interests there's someone like Bill
Maher I think his aunt Eve acts for the
most part he's firmly on the Left but
yes but there it's it's skeptic
skepticism of authority which authority
are you skeptical of the government or
the corporations and the perception is
both have these incredible amounts of
power and studies on this show they
really don't have as much power as we
think that they do
I mean CEOs come and go and and
corporations rise and fall much more
than we think that they do we think of
you know the Microsoft's of the world
you know even Google Apple they will
fade they will you know they're on top
now but this will change just like you
know IBM General Motors and you know so
oh but I was in Berkeley last week
promoting the skeptic book I did talk
for a KPFA Pacifica Radio which is very
far left progressive and so is that this
church which was kind of wild that big
cross behind me but there are protesters
there at the protesters oh my god what
is this about you know and they're
handing out literature you know the
engineers and architects for 9/11 truth
and and Shermer versus reality building
seven could not have collect you know I
saw you tweet something about this
yeah so there okay this is a so this is
that the government is you know pulling
the strings and doing these things
because of oil and the war and so it's
after the fact reason he's the inside by
so we went to war was a big bad idea but
we did it for oil therefore we must have
triggered the war in the first place
don't governments don't conservative and
Republican administrations do those
sorts of things yes so do Democratic you
know you know Roosevelt could not get
America into the war to help Churchill
who he wanted to help because of the
American Firsters were very powerful in
the late 30s and they could all see the
Nazis rising and Roosevelt in Churchill
wanted to do something about it and but
Charles Lindbergh and the American
firsters were very powerful Pearl Harbor
and the story we're going to war so
isn't that an example of using an event
that you didn't orchestrate to do
something politically you want to do
everybody sounds it sounds like a nice
conspiracy theory that they knew it was
gonna happen and they allowed it so
there was two conspiracies about that
and same 9/11 either either they they
did it or they knew it would happen and
allowed it to happen
in order to get this political motive
nothing neither of them are true right
and the reason we know this is because
the evidence that's used in favor of the
conspiracy is all along is hindsight
bias is that look look at this memo here
the famous August 9th memo from
Condoleezza Rice yes you know some Abid
line will attack on US soil Wow Holcomb
Bush didn't do something about that
because there is 10,000 pieces of info
like that every week and then you're
sorting through it and no one's talking
to each other you know it's just chaos
so are you ever able to debunk a
conspiracy theory to a point where the
theorists themselves will concede it
because that's sort of the fun in it
there's no end right so even if you lay
down something that is just ironclad
still they're gonna find some way to get
around that I do I mean how often do you
win in that you know wins I don't know
to the people that I'm debating or
talking to probably no probably never
but we're after is again the undecided
voters the people that are like yeah
what's the story with that I heard
something about that memo oh I see and
then they okay forget it nevermind
right nothing to that and you try to
influence them by just some you know
basic questions you know like I rifled
through all the all the other things
that Islamic terrorists have done you
know London and Madrid and Boston and
you know the African countries and so on
and so on are they also part of this you
know vast right-wing conspiracy that the
bush them no no of course not but that
particular one yeah which is a little
bit like okay we know those crop circles
were faked but the ones over here we
don't have videos there those are the
real ones
yeah and there's also seems to be a need
to explain things that can't easily be
explained so even going back to the
cologne thing I saw that day a fairly
well-known feminist saying this was
probably the work of anti-immigration
people but you know anything that
allowed this happen because she didn't
want to really deal with the world as it
was and deal with the difficult
questions related to immigration and
race and religion and all of that you
know so instead you kind of use it for
your own purposes and then you just open
up another conspiracy theory and then
that gets retweeted enough and then
you've opened up a whole other yeah in
that case it's okay to just call
[ __ ] just that well that's what I
did this is a bridge